are you officially like the first
avenger
slash producer of the bunch on their of
their own standalone film
yes you know i have to say uh that
actually
in many ways was my greatest
accomplishment
on this film okay ladies i just gotta
start by saying y'all
did the damn thing this movie is so
so good congratulations hey
man i was like yo this is amazing i
i can't believe first of all that i came
to the set back in i guess was july or
august of 2019.
it feels like ages ago doesn't it it
really doesn't a lot has happened let's
be honest
darling i'm gonna start with you because
you know i was a little bit clumped i
have to say at the end of it because i
felt like okay this is the end of an era
it is the end
of black widow how are you feeling about
that have you
processed it and wrapped your brain
around it yet you know i think
it's part of this pandemic time
obviously none of us could have ever
you know foreseen the the release of
this film would
take this long or why it would take this
long but one of the
benefits i think of this period which
has been
very challenging for so many people in
so many ways but one of the benefits is
that i've had a lot of
time to think and be self-reflective and
you know to prioritize and honestly
i mean we had such a wonderful
experience making this film
we have such an incredible creative
group of people it was made with so much
love
and i feel really good about it i mean
yeah i'm for clump too
you know i have bittersweet feelings
about it it's hard it's
you know eggs aches a little bit in my
heart but i also
love this movie so much i love this
character so much and i feel like
it's okay to set it free it's ending on
a high note
and i feel really positive about it
[Music]
you're welcome i don't have to ask what
it's like the chemistry on set cause
number one i've seen it firsthand
i have to watch out for her all the time
because she tries to trip me a lot um
into giving me hugs
snuggly it feels like that y'all been
like
you know sisters for a really long time
right that's what i keep on telling
carla she's like you're the sister i
never wanted
literally she's like i don't want to
adopt you
get out of my mouth here's what's going
to happen natasha don't
slouch i'm not slouching you're going to
get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
well i couldn't help but notice um the
executive producer
scarlett johansson on that we love to
see it we love to see it are you
officially
like the first avenger slash producer
of the bunch on their of their own
standalone film
yes come on come on come on
come on you better do it
i mean as much as you've done like that
executive producer
credit and that means something like
that does something to me seeing that
it def it definitely does i you know i
have to say
that actually in many ways was my
greatest accomplishment on this film uh
was being able to executive produce it
and uh you know carve this out of
[Music]
nothing
we made the movie because we wanted to
not because we had to which was
liberating in a lot of ways and you know
really got to focus on what we thought
was the most important part of natasha's
story and uh
and that this is the result of that i
love that
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story lawrence we had to
give her her flowers real quick okay we
had
we had you know we had to give them to
her
but i want to talk to you too about the
chemistry between the two of you because
it's bananas
and when you are imitating those black
widow poses
it sent me yeah it also sent scarlet
that's like 10 years of work and it's
down the drain
[Laughter]
one one little one annoying little girl
coming to set and thinking she can take
to piss out a thing that i thought i was
really good at doing
at some point we all have to choose
[Music]
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
you know one of my favorite lines in
this movie is
we're still killers you're just a killer
that little girls look up to as a hero
okay but talk to me about actually
deciding to deconstruct
natasha as a superhero and how you
wanted to go about that because she does
have a gray area i mean a lot of the
avengers have a bit of a gray area she
does
yes she um of course she does i mean
she's
uh been a part of a large organization
for her
entire life um and i think
you know that there's a lot of gray in
that obviously you're working
oftentimes towards you know
a greater goal for better or worse and
it's not
driven by any personal desire i mean
that was
that was thanos's big argument and the
marvel universe has played with that
idea a lot even in ultron how many
people
you know um you know are our
casualties for like a greater
good how many how many is acceptable and
cap has always said zero
you know and it's been a bit of big our
debate that's what civil war was even
about
you know and um you know so there is a
lot of gray area there and i think that
you know natasha is really
in this film reckoning with the
trauma that she has faced and she's been
running away from and it's it's
a gray area that she had no active
choice in
but has felt so guilty about and not
understood
or been able to really deal with the you
know the
uh trauma that she's experienced because
of that
it's good to see you too sis
what brings you home
and it's elena who allows her to you
know
whether even like forces her to reflect
on that stuff so she can move past it
yeah scarlett you know um i need to know
what was in the water on that set
because both you
and david decided to get married during
the pandemic
so what how special was it for you to
find that little moment of peace in the
crazy
you know world and year that we had yeah
i think you know honestly it's
um it's again i think it's been
it's been a time where um all of us have
been able to step back and
just reflect on what's most important
and um
you know i think when you can get
through what we've all
been through this past uh you know year
and a half and you come out the other
side and you're
you're like okay you're the person you
want you're in the we're in the foxhole
you know and we did it
um you know that's really significant
you